too well here
set to become parents in just two weeks
but first a tight embrace
it's been so painful to know that my
extended family are still there every
day we hope that the war is going to go
down but realistically we know it's
going to continue
reem's husband Naji arrived in London
today on one of the final flights out of
heartum
there are witness reports of dogs
ripping at corpses of people whose
numbers may not have been included in
the 500 reported to have died
Naji showed us this video sent to him
it's said to have been filmed at the
start of the war and appears to show
bodies on the streets of bahri in
Northern hartum clothing even carpets
used to give the dead some respect
It's haunting how the wounded sit in
silence
I would call it a ghost town and the
worst thing is not knowing where we were
running to and not knowing who we could
run to
running wouldn't be enough Naji had to
get on a flight it is a seemingly
impossible task when your passport is
inside a now closed British Embassy
when I arrived at the Airfield they put
an x on my hand that signals a person
can't leave the country
even with this cross Naji and Rheem were
determined they got help from a British
charity they applied legally at the
embassy with their marriage certificate
and to be denied because he didn't get
his passport back him and tens of
thousands of other people was hard to uh
to accept
Naji got on one of the last flights out
another one landed tonight
those remaining have been given a
deadline to board the last flight
tomorrow it is for British Nationals
only Sadia Chaudhary Sky News